foreign
welcome to another world language design
review as we get ready for the first
code freeze for version 13.3
um and we are talking about some
compiler
things
which should I look at first sequence
types okay kernel evaluate first
okay
all right so this is this is in some
ways a a sort of different version of
something similar to Kernel function
so essentially what kernel evaluate does
is
the simplest usage is it just provides a
block of code that will get run in the
evaluator as opposed to the compiler and
you can use it inside the middle of your
compiled code and the other usages are
just so that you can uh refer to
variables from the compiler in your
evaluated code
right but why is that thing that looks
like a function and kernel function
what let me remind myself how kernel
function works
right so kernel function is for you know
is essentially a subset of Kernel
evaluates
you have to pass arguments to the kernel
function
um whereas and your sub value as sub
values yes
yes
what does kernel function do
by the way why on Earth is that
signature for kernel function not
described up here
what do you mean that signature
oh no I'm sorry I'm sorry I type is
outside yeah
Okay so
kernel evaluate
is taking its arguments
is evaluating that expression having
entrained certain variables correct
can you give a pure function as the as a
kernel function yes
that's why these are these are pretty
similar
but I think there are a lot of uses for
kernel evaluate is a lot more readable
yes
so so an example of a kernel function so
here's you know for the one argument
kernel evaluates you could imagine
writing something like
um you know
absolute time open close or I don't know
something with you know something it
doesn't take any arguments but but where
you know you still want to run it in the
evaluator
you know when you run the compiler if
that may or when you run the compiled
code right
um the what the the multi-argument cases
are basically if you want to you know
import variables
it's basically like if you want to say
here's my compiled program but this part
right in the middle here I want to
evaluate that not compile it
I'm actually very confused how does this
how does the scoping of this ARG work
here so the the outside are so it's okay
right so basically our I mean that it's
an argument to the function that you're
compiling right but that outer Arc you
could also Imagine That being a module
variable or something like that any
variable thing
yep then kernel evaluate is kind of like
a scoping construct itself
where you basically say the the thing at
the beginning is a bit like a with spec
or something where you're just saying
like here's the list of variable or
maybe like a module spec you're saying
here's the list of variables that I want
to capture from the compiler environment
and you know make available for the
evaluated environment
yes
yes but
right but it's kind of an anti-scoping
because what it's doing it's a capturing
not a not a scoping yeah it's a
capturing yeah sure right
are you sure the argument order is right
then for kernel evaluate
I think it's supposed it should look
like with or like any of those scoping
things that's the concept
or even like function function also
takes but remember those are not
capturing those are not external
captures in other words kernel
evaluating what you're doing is the name
of the first argument
is in the global environment all those
other things like function the name is
meaningless it's it's a local you know
it's a local variable
I guess so yeah
so this is really a different thing this
is a this is a capturing the name
well for example like it's actually
quite similar to function except that
the value of the function comes from the
environment as opposed to from the
argument
right
but it actually I mean even I mean this
doesn't matter that much but on a
technical level I think it does use with
so I could use this like expression
replacement like function or with wood
right
and and inside its body it's lexically
skunked
but how does it get okay I'm now totally
totally confused if I say for example
let's say I just say
uh
you know I say kernel evaluate
of I've got something that says X Plus
kernel evaluate of X comma x squared
by the way are you in an old I think
you're not in a 13-3 yeah I'm not on a
33 yeah this is I mean if I would
recommend you try and run it yourself
because it will compile quickly but um
okay I mean so assuming that X is some
variable in the local environment right
first of all obviously you never
actually need to write that because you
know exercises but yeah I mean so
basically it's it's saying X Plus and
then and then here's an evaluated block
which I think was the original name of
this was evaluated block
you know and we're just saying that
basically X needs to be available in the
evaluated block
yes I understand but but but what is
different between this and function for
example is function specifically doesn't
care
the name f okay so look or I I
understand I understand what you're
saying I mean arguably there's some
things with block where it you know it
is aware of the things outside of it if
that makes sense yes I understand
especially inherited block although
that's not documented I don't think
right
okay so the point is
and and why is it that it needs to
reference that it needs to mention these
variables why can't it just see that
there are variables there and use them
it probably can do sort of Wizardry to
see what variables are used but it's
iffy and like for example if you have
the you know symbolic expression x
squared but X is not actually a capture
variable
you know like they're all sorts of weird
like for example suppose it sees that
you wrote you know full simplify of x
squared you know over x squared or
something like that right so it doesn't
actually matter what the x is suppose
that there's no compiler variable called
X in scope
that that would probably correctly be
identified as an error because it would
say oh well I see that use this variable
X in your evaluated code but I actually
can't capture any X from the compiler
environment
right
does that make sense yeah
surely we should say in the kernel or
something in the oh we debate yeah yeah
so in kernel so I mean one the original
thing we wrote was like wolf from
language kernel
but then uh kernel function says
something slightly weirder it says Like
the Wolf from engine kernel right
um which is probably a little bit wrong
yeah then there's like you've got kernel
function open okay right another one is
uh using the term evaluator which is
used in one of the document one of the
examples I think for kernel function
well but maybe we could say the kernel
evaluator
to be evaluated in the
why don't we say in the main Wolfram
language kernel that sounds like there
might be other kernels and also if
you're doing this in some parallel
evaluation
well I mean
what do we say that the compiler is
evaluating in
what's the greatest
raw native code
I I don't know that anywhere I think we
just say compiled code in a bunch of
places right like we have for example
things that say XYZ is suitable for use
in compiled code
foreign
language kernel here I think wolfen
engine is its own branded headless
animal
um but let's go back to this okay yeah
so kind of evaluate
look I mean oh my gosh
we we do we have used and I think you
you wrote These like look at function
compile that talks about use the Wolfram
engine rather than being compiled into
low-level code
um now we can we can change this well in
the function compile right so look at
function compile and look at the notes
there's a note
yeah that one there's one there
well
uh
sorry the oh it should directly use dorf
Mandarin
I think we should change that should
directly use the woven language kernel
I I can go and make changes like those
if we agree on the I think we should I
think we agreed about that
um
but do we actually use kernel is that
our terminology
well yes and look at the name of this
function
that might be true right what's the
language kernel I will make changes like
those okay all right so let's just talk
about this capturing thing because I
think it's it's um
um
I would say something like captures
the variable X from the compiled code to
be used in the evaluated code
so
I'm not necessarily opposed to that one
thing is that I think the word captures
sounds a lot like closures which is not
really what I thought it was this is
but let me just go through again what
this really is
this is saying okay let's review why it
cares right why can it not just
lexically see there's an X here and
there's an X I mean
you've already declared every variable
that's here
is it true that every variable is
declared yes in a compiler yes okay but
right right out this example okay so
write out you know you imagine if your
compiled function just make a function
so it's clear this is the whole thing
you know it doesn't take any arguments
and then uh you know kernel evaluate of
um you know
I don't know he was a dumb one you know
simplify of X over X
you know close bracket plus two
yeah you you don't want automatic
capturing you you you don't well the the
bigger problem is that uh you know okay
so that obviously returns a three and it
needs but but now if you imagine writing
something on another line where you just
write kernel evaluate of you know X plus
two
the the problem is it can't I would
argue that kernel value of x plus two
like
right like you kind of want that to fail
you don't want it to just sort of say no
until we have a symbolic until we can
compile symbolic things well we can if
you did typed inertia expression it
would be completely fine
right that that that's true right that's
that's true which also makes it really
confusing so I mean the point being that
I think it's it is
right now basically you know you tell it
what variables you want and if those
variables don't exist in the compiler it
fails if it were detecting it
automatically at least right now it
wouldn't be able to have any failure
case like that because we just have to
assume oh I bet that's just a variable
that's meant to be symbolic right and I
think that'll lead to really weird stuff
yep
okay hold on hold on so the basic Su is
but we can probably you know I think
this is a bit defensive because later we
can always add
you know inferencing like that to the
one argument case right but I think it
would be a mistake to add broken
reasoning like that to the one argument
case that we can't get rid of
yeah fine I agree but I mean then
um
um I mean I think here we should say
something like
um
makes X available for use in expert
that's better
makes the compiled variable
well isn't that what passes means
yeah I guess although past has maybe
implies that it's like passing it to a
function yeah
and passes usually is by value
right which is which is not what's
happening here it's not passing X by
value it's making X as you say available
well actually I think it is passing it
by value because
actually I'm trying to remember now if
you
actually talk do you remember like I you
can't set X inside of the value right
you you you can't okay yeah
you should say so it is basically say
that by value yeah but that's a fine
note to have but it's all right okay so
uh it would be fine captures the
compiled variable X for use in compiled
code
so you're using evaluated code
use in
the use in the evaluation of expert yeah
fine
so let's make these changes yeah yeah do
that do that great perfect
so to be to be clear also
right so what this actually turns into
is it turns into like a width block
right where you know all the variables
you declared or you know variable
how about captures the value of the
compiled variable X
to use
in the evaluation
or for use in the evaluation of
fine
okay and while we're at it I might as
well just add the note that says um
uh
the expert cannot modify x i
or something
well I mean but by the time
it's sort of implied by this but it
should say yeah um say it anyway
right
um
the
evaluation of expert cannot modify
the value
in
in kernel evaluate
the evaluation of expert cannot modify
the value of x
okay
all right
[Music]
um
okay
okay I guess it just makes sense
all right
should we look at sequence type
sure
this seems yeah
sorry what's that yeah what you're going
to say about kernel evaluate no I mean I
think I I'm I'm buying into the fact
that kernel function is the you know the
rapper
that has
it's
variable values passed in yeah it makes
it all makes sense
good yep
and I was saying sequence type is a lot
more mind-bending
so oh dear yes then kernel evaluate
for sure
so this is a type construct that's
analogous to sequence so so it's
basically the way you do bear arcs
functions in the compiler okay
dude I'm talking for all time
that might be a relative
um
right so basically if you look at like
the first example for all type Maybe
or I guess the usage lines too but okay
right so if you look at that first
example right so here you know T the
variable T just refers to like a single
it's like a a blank a single blank
you know it's like this is some type
sequence type if you look at the first
example of that on the right hand side
you can say sequence type T and that
basically means that
it's like saying that it basically
implies that t is actually a triple
blank
and
you know
right we can have any
you can have whatever School blank type
so we've the one of the things we've
talked about doing which is a bigger
project that you know is
kind of theoretical right now is the
idea of trying to unify a bunch of types
and text stuff of patterns
there are some arguments I think there
are various reasons it would be nice
there are also some problems with it
like that there are lots of pattern
constructs that are just fundamentally
don't make sense as type constructs so
it'd be kind of a fake subject
probably and vice versa as well sorry
maybe yeah yeah but so right so at least
for now types are not trying to look
like patterns but look when you do down
value compilation you're absolutely
going to want to take you know
configurations of blanks and turn them
into into types aren't you
well yes probably orthogonal that's
that's that's a different thing you know
right that that happens internally
but it's not exposed
okay okay all right sequence type then
right
so that's a type maybe look at the first
example because otherwise it'll be
really hard to understand not that the
first example is particularly easy to
understand
so so basically that type okay that type
represents that it's a machine integer
followed by some sequence of things
represented by T
and it returns a machine integer yes
then you see that the definition there
are two definitions that were used for
this function right so one of them
uh right so the first one basically it's
like a fold so it's taking that first
integer and adding it to ver arg's ad of
the rest right and there's the base case
when you give it a single integer in
that case the sequence type is you know
I think it's zero essentially and then
uh right and then now you have a varrox
function
that it's a sequence type
means I mean in terms of type Theory I
understand that it's it's in terms of
you know symbolic Expressions why is
this complicated I mean maybe it's not
if you don't find it complicated thing
that's great well maybe I didn't
understand it I mean I I'm
uh
it's just a type that represents a
sequence of
of Watts well
of any things and then it's implied you
see in this example it implies that it
has to be a machine integer because you
see that the you know when it when it
recurses there won't be a usage you know
if you had a float in the middle of or a
reel or something right then there
wouldn't be any usage of this ad
function which matches that signature
yes with a you know reel on the first
argument right
because the function declaration here
is using that type yeah I mean
okay if you find this easy to understand
then I think maybe I'm totally confused
but it does seem I don't think you are
okay well I think this is fine I mean
the
looks good to me
great
um is this are you guys putting this
stuff onto guide Pages appropriately yes
I'll do that but I just wanted you you
know I don't want to do this and then
fine we rename it and I'll unfuturize
these and and do appropriate knitting
and stuff okay I'm about to I'm going to
push back these um I'm gonna do an
update to push those files back
fantastic right
I'll take care of that and I'll look at
the other stuff that you have as well
okay sounds good right okay okay thanks
everyone okay bye okay bye bye bye-bye
right
foreign